so if you increase price by one unit
quantity goes down my name's Paul lair
and I'm an economist the t-statistic for
the tests of P equals zero is 1.76
I teach executives and MBA students at
Stanford Graduate School of Business but
I believe the economic principles I
teach in the classrooms don't just apply
to Silicon Valley startups and fortune
500 companies in fact I'm part of a
group of three economists that's always
trying to study small business in its
own environment now I'm hitting the road
with my economist friends
Scott Shafer from the University of Utah
it's given us a lot of respect and
admiration for the people who run small
business it's an intellectually
challenging position and Mike Maggio
from Northwestern University's Kellogg
School of Management
really interesting characters fun people
great storytellers to visit small
businesses across America learn what it
takes to make a dollar and find out how
everyday Americans are making economics
work for damage